this is what can happen when fear and
misinformation collide on these buses
our evacuation China headed for
coronavirus quarantine in central
Ukraine 45 Ukrainians 27 Argentinians
and people from several other countries
- the angry crowds are from the village
of Navi San Shari trying to keep them
out
riot police struggled to keep order
they'd arrived in Kiev earlier on
Thursday president vladimir Zielinski
tried to reassure ukrainians that there
was no danger
officials said everyone flown in have
been screened twice for the virus and
criticized the growing protests muslim
Simla by she may yet stop we can see how
such people are treated in other
countries where there is the disease and
what is going on in Ukraine in my
opinion we cannot allow such attitudes
towards our citizens but a hoax email
claiming to come from the Health
Ministry was already stoking fears it
had falsely stated that there were five
coronavirus cases in the country when
actually there were none the anxiety
spread why drive them 350 kilometers
from Kiev across half of Ukraine to an
inhabited area where people live right
next to the buildings where they will be
accommodated isn't there any other place
in Ukraine that can host 50 people that
is located in more less remote villages
or in 4 areas where there is no threat
to the population so why do we need them
yes why do we need this our children go
there all our children with a brief to
restore calm the Prime Minister was
dispatched in Navi Sanjar II where a
vacuous are now in two weeks quarantine
as a gesture our Health Minister has
agreed to stay with the citizens in this
medical institution this way her example
will prove that there is no danger to
Ukrainian citizens it is a very decent
position we are very grateful to our
colleague from the government Friday has
so far seen no repeat of Thursday's
panic authorities will hope it stays
that way
Rory challon's al-jazeera